new short-term rental regulations
officially in place now for the city of
las vegas now those in clark county saw
revisions that was back in june as of
now hosts there must enter a lottery
system in order to get a license to
operate madison kimbrough spoke to a
homeowner who's not happy with the
change
what are my chances of getting the the
license to go on with this business with
all the restrictions they put it leslie
a short-term rental host for the past
five years is mad about the changes she
owns a home in unincorporated clark
county and must enter a lottery in hopes
of getting a license out of the
estimated 10 to 12 thousand short-term
rentals that exist in the county only
about 2 800 will get licensed they're
denying us
the ability to make a passive income i'm
82 i can't do a physical income my
husband died and i sort of forced into
this because in an older house like this
things deteriorate and when i had a
husband he'd fix him when anything goes
wrong here now i have to hire somebody
on wednesday the city of las vegas
adopted their own regulations for
short-term rentals including not
allowing homeowners to run out their
entire house to vacation rental
companies such as airbnb and verbo other
regulations only allowing those who live
on the property to rent out a room in
their house that have three bedrooms or
less and distance requirements from the
strip a requirement of 660 feet between
rental properties jackie flores with the
greater las vegas short-term rental
association sued the county and soon the
city for what she says is violations of
rights different municipalities here
have different
regulations but they all have a problem
and one of those problems is that they
are attacking homeowners property rights
and a lot of those rules and regulations
that they have violate not just u.s the
u.s constitution but the nevada
constitution as well madison kimbrough 8
news now